your mind can either dictate you and
tell you oh I'm not going to make it a
mile or 2 mil or 20 mi or 70 Mi or you
can put your mind as the co-pilot and
have that Synergy with your mind and
work together I say it's bigger than the
running because there's so much more
value now I can find and answer
questions I can answer questions on my
own life I can break
down okay why is my marriage not working
why is this not working okay I can do
this to make better sense of how I talk
to my child oh this is a different
Factor just taking the earbuds out cuz
that was another piece I used to run
with music and then I took the music out
and then I started listening to the
birds and then I started listening to my
breath and listening to my feet on the
concrete and then that's when it made
sense and I was like ah this is why they
come hand in hand